俺が大学2年生だったとき事業を受けるために大学の階段を上っていた
皆前のちょっと綺麗な女子大生の人が歩いてたんですけど
スカートがリックに挟まっててパンツ丸見えで歩いていたんですよ
俺は悩んだ果たして彼女にそのことを言っていいのかまあそれがそれ言っちゃうと
パンツ見たいということ断定的に説明していることになるけど言わないと彼女はその
リックに使うと挟んだがまぁ授業を受ける教室まで一気もっと大勢のシェルパンツを見
られてしまう
俺はないので結果
恥ずかしくて言えませんでしたこんにちははじめ社長です世の中には言ってはいけない
こともあると思いますやマジでね言わないほうが幸せなことも多いかもしれないけど
そりゃ言うべきなのかもしれないとこう決めるのはやっぱ皆さんしないです何が正しい
かは僕からは言いませんが打っていいことと悪いことを言わなくていい春日言った方が
いい真実がそこの見極め非常に
おかしいところなんですけども今回僕は今からちょっと公共に行かなきゃいけないん
ですけどこの僕のいいから oo 今日の僕の事務所まで行く間に僕は両派に歯ブラシ
をぶっさしていこうと思いますミスったんでしょ
寝ぼけててあと鼻を間違えて両肩に歯ブラシを入れてしまったという大きなミスを犯し
たという設定で新幹線に乗り米山よりタクシーに乗り住所ができます
ホンギの非常に難しいとこだところで端に歯ブラシが入ってひょっとしたら花粉対策か
もしれない人と者がそれ趣味の方がもしれないはたまた
パーンなのかもしれんまたそのことを言って良いのは言わない方がいいのかっていうと
みなさんのメっちゃっぷちょちょっぽっちゃねちょっと皆さんの高知行き調査的な実験
的にやってるぞい
もう時間ないから方へ行きます東京未来子
tan
トゥデイ
ん
グーン
gee
true
うん
お願いします
いい天気ですね
はっはっは
それガール
bea
するのでああ
ありがとうございました
tee
car
me
wh
earena
andore
た
me
ああああああ
mar をん
ええええええ
ああああああ
car
歯ブラシが鼻に困ってますありがとう室
j
th
味がある全体です
そうです
という方漢族ルートパパわかりやすかったです
そこです
そう笑ぐらいです